>> VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
ASKING HIM ABOUT THAT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE UNDER THE SUN.
>> I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH.
I CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
I MEAN, I COULD, BUT I CAN'T.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER I CAN
ANSWER THAT, RACHEL.
I DON'T THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
AS I SIT HERE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A RELATED
QUESTION THAT I ALSO DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN ANSWER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> COME ON, HE'S GOT TO KNOW
SOMETHING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M NOT PERMITTED TO ANSWER
THAT.
I HAVE NO PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE OF
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
AND IF I DID, I WOULDN'T SAY.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU MORE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU COULD ANSWER.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAD NO IDEA.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
I CAN'T RECALL.
THAT'S ANOTHER ONE I CAN'T
ANSWER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GUESS HE DOESN'T KNOW.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> ALL RIGHT.
COMEY, STORMY, TWO PEAS IN A
POD, ONE HAD A BOOK, ANOTHER HAD
A SKETCH AND THEY TRIED TO OUTDO
EACH OTHER IN A GAME OF
PUBLICITY PING-PONG.
>> I THOUGHT HONESTLY THAT HE
WAS, YOU KNOW, SORT OF HANDSOME
>>.
YOU REALIZE I'M KIND OF AN
HONEST IDIOT.
I THINK I'M A GOOD PERSON.
DURING THE SALAD BEFORE THE
SHRIMP.
>> I'M A BETTER ACCESS THAN HE
IS.
WOMEN LIKE ME MATTER.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE TOO TOUGH
ON MYSELF.
>> I'M DONE BEING BULLIED.
>> OH, YEAH.
NOW AS FOR THOSE COMEY MEMOS, I
GOT MORE OF A SHOCK TAKING MY
TUBE SOCKS OUT OF THE DRYER.
I'M SORRY, THE COLLUSION SEEMS
MORE BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA THAN ANYONE ELSE.
BUT IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT, YOU
ARE THINKING THIS STUFF ISN'T
WORKING, WHAT DO WE DO NOW?
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
FILED A FEDERAL LAWSUIT IN
MANHATTAN AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE, WIKILEAKS
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ALLEGING
DAMAGE TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AS A RESULT OF THE HACK IN THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
THEY ARE SUING RUSSIA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ANOTHER NEW AVENUE BECAUSE
ALL THE OTHER PREVIOUS ONES ARE
DEAD END.
WHEN IDIOTS DON'T GET WHAT THEY